bienvenidos a la presentación acerca de
cómo multiplicar y dividir números con
distintos signos lo que voy a hacer es
demostrarles que es en realidad algo muy
sencillo si se aprenden unas cuantas
reglas que son muy fácil y estás y
quizás en algún vídeo posterior les dé
un poco de intuición acerca de por qué
esas reglas funcionan así que bueno
vamos a comenzar primero que nada
imaginemos que tenemos tenemos un número
negativo multiplicado por otro número
negativo digamos menos 2 x menos 2 esto
es un número negativo por otro número
negativo ahora si hago 2 x 2
el resultado es 4 pero si tengo un
número negativo multiplicado por otro
número negativo el resultado será un
número positivo así que esa es nuestra
primera regla
un negativo x otro negativo siempre me
dará un número positivo bien continuemos
qué pasa ahora si tengo un número
negativo como menos 2 x un número
positivo como 2 pues de nuevo si me
olvido de los signos si simplemente hago
dos por dos el resultado sería 4 pero en
este caso es un negativo por un positivo
así que el resultado será negativo y esa
es otra de nuestras reglas
en el caso de que haga un negativo por
un positivo el resultado siempre será un
negativo
bien qué pasa ahora si los cambios lugar
si hago 2 x menos 2
y si se fijan por la propiedad de la
conmuta actividad de la multiplicación
estas dos cosas son iguales así que me
debe dar lo mismo también me da menos 4
por lo tanto también un positivo por un
negativo me da un negativo
así que en realidad estas dos reglas son
la misma finalmente si yo tengo un
positivo por otro positivo ustedes ya
saben que el resultado de eso será
positivo será 4 normal bien así que
vamos a notar las reglas lo que hemos
concluido es que si multiplico
cantidades con signos iguales
signos iguales
entonces el resultado será positivo
positivo no importa que las cantidades
sean negativas ambas siempre será
positivo si son 2 negativos o 2
positivos por el contrario si tengo
signos distintos
tintos entonces el resultado será
negativo
negativo como en este caso está acá o
también en este caso así que por ejemplo
por ejemplo si hago uno por uno como
tienen signos iguales el resultado será
uno positivo pero también si hago menos
uno por menos uno los signos de nuevo
aunque sean negativos como son iguales
el resultado será positivo así que esto
también me da uno
pero si por el contrario
hago
1 x menos 1 entonces el resultado será
menos 1 puesto que estos dos tienen
signos contrarios o también si hago
menos uno por uno eso también será menos
uno bien vamos a hacer aún más ejemplos
para practicar de hecho les recomiendo
que pausa en este vídeo cuando sea
necesario y vayan resolviendo los
ejercicios y secando sus respuestas
mientras avanzamos bien como primer
ejemplo vamos a considerar el producto
de menos 4 por 3 ahora bien lo primero
que hago es olvidarme de los signos y
hago 4 por 3 que sería 12 ahora como
menos 4 y 3 tienen signos distintos
entonces el resultado es negativo por lo
tanto esto es igual a menos 12 que hay
de menos 2 x menos 7
menos dos por menos siete en sí hago dos
por siete el resultado sería 14
ahora como los dos signos son iguales es
menos y menos son dos números negativos
el resultado es 14 positivo
qué hay de por ejemplo 9 x menos 5
9 x 5 sería 45 como los signos son
distintos el resultado debe ser negativo
así que esto es menos 45
que hay también de menos 6 x menos 11
seis por once sería 66 y los signos son
iguales así que el resultado es positivo
podría ponerles tema siquiera bien ahora
una canción que hay de 0 x menos 12
pues 0 por cualquier cosa es 0 además de
que 0 no es ni positivo ni negativo así
que estas reglas no aplican 0 por
cualquier cosa es 0 muy bien ahora vamos
a pasar a la división y veremos que en
realidad las mismas reglas se aplican
bien entonces para la división
vamos a usar exactamente las mismas
reglas
por ejemplo 9 entre 9 entre menos 3 nos
olvidamos del signo y decimos 9 entre 3
y 3 como tienen signos distintos el
resultado es negativo así que es menos 3
bien ahora menos 16
entre 8
16 entre 8 olvidándonos del signo es 2
negativo entre positivo son signos
distintos así que de nuevo el resultado
es negativo y no importa que el signo
menos aparezca en el numerador o en el
denominador siempre si tengo un positivo
entre un negativo el resultado será
negativo y si tengo un negativo entre un
positivo el resultado será negativo
pero qué hay de por ejemplo menos 54 /
- 6
fue 54 entre 6 y 9 pero ahora los signos
son iguales es un negativo entre un
negativo así que el resultado será
positivo
muy bien ahora una canción a cero entre
menos uno
pues 0 / cualquier cosa es cero así que
aquí no hay nada que hacer sólo tengan
cuidado de no dividir entre cero el cero
puede aparecer siendo dividido pero no
dividiendo ok uno último 4 /
- 1 en este caso 4 entre 1 es 4 positivo
entre negativo son signos distintos así
que el resultado es negativo muy bien
espero que estos ejemplos les hayan
ayudado por favor chequen la página y
realicen muchos ejemplos porque esto es
cuestión de práctica también los invito
a que piensen porque las reglas que
hemos usado funcionan pero bueno es
importante hacer muchos muchos
ejercicios inventen sus propios
ejercicios porque el punto de todo esto
es aprender que regla usar en qué
momento hasta la próxima